many of you over the last 24 48 Hours
wrote to me about some very particular
statements made by former 60 Minutes
journalist Lara Logan that are quite
frankly utterly deranged now I don't
know how many in the audience know the
trajectory of Lara Logan but Lara Logan
was at one point sort of a respectable
journalist and she has increasingly gone
down the conspiracy Rabbit Hole over the
last year we've talked about her
anti-semitic conspiracy theories
anti-vaccine conspiracy theories covid
medical disinformation just a sort of
all of the above type thing I don't know
whether this is a character she's
playing or whether she really is off the
rails but I am going to show you a
couple of clips of what happens when you
really are infected by proverbial brain
worms Lara Logan was interviewed by
Newsmax two days ago
and she claims to have spoken to a man
who infiltrated the global cabal at the
U.N even she seems confused by what
she's claiming it is bit very scary
stuff I would get the kids out of the
room for this one but you know what it's
even bigger than that because um I you
know I I spoke to a man who was actually
holding the documents in his hand he
told me about it right he said he was uh
he infiltrated the global uh cabal at
the UN level right and one of the things
that he was able to
um to to tell me about from his own
personal experience what he witnessed
himself was these documents that showed
that the plan there is a plan and this
was several years ago right the plan was
to infiltrate 100 million illegal
immigrants and at that point they were
already at 40 million now think about
how insane this is
infiltrate 100 million undocumented
immigrants to the United States a third
of the U.S population I mean it does no
matter what state you live in this
doesn't even pass the sniff test just
think about what that would mean in
terms of our daily lives it it's not
even remotely plausible and these people
would dilute what they called the pool
of Patriots those with their words right
yeah now that's that's great replacement
stuff we we've talked about that for a
while that's the idea of a concerted uh
plan by democrats to replace white
people with non-white people in order to
control this that and this is Tucker
Carlson's stuff but just with slightly
less eloquent language
and they would not be taught that
America is a great country and trained
to sing the national anthem with pride
and they wouldn't be trained to sing the
national anthem think about that
language
we train people to sing the national
anthem with pride
sounds sounds pretty authoritarian
fascistic someone and so on they would
be told all the negative things that
were told about the us today that our
own children are told and and what would
be the effect of diluting the pool of
Patriots well it would be to break down
this sense of pride in being American
and what it means to be American yeah
really really scary stuff and to think
that just I don't know what was it a
decade ago she really was a pretty
respectable journalist doing pretty
respectable journalism she also you know
it's it's not just anti-science it's not
just conspiracies but it's also this
pseudo-religious stuff where she's not
necessarily
saying that these are her Christian
beliefs but she's talking about Satan as
if Satan is a sort of conscious actor
with agency listen to this Bonkers stuff
it's right out of it's right out of the
Playbook the right out of the Socialist
Playbook you divide conquer you don't
tell me your intent you get people to
come in you got your useful idiots those
of us who are paying for these people to
have all these luxuries and they lie
about it yeah how's it end
well
it's bad news for some
um okay so on a serious note
um you know people of all faiths have
said to me that this is a spiritual
battle I am a fern and solid and
immovable believer in God now understand
that what what do you mean you're saying
the Muslims came to you and that this is
a spiritual battle against
immigrants who are mostly religious also
the Jews came to you the Buddhists
everybody's coming to you saying Lara
these are really battles of Faith
against the immigrants what the hell are
you talking about and I believe that God
wins I believe that good is greater than
evil and I believe that the Fallen Angel
otherwise known as Satan doesn't get to
Prevail in this world so um if you
follow the Bible or if you follow the
Quran or you follow the Book of Mormon
you know people talk in various
different ways about the end times and
if you fight for God the end times guys
the end times God will fight for you but
people Humanity
final thought though I have to I have to
ask you this because my audience is very
God-fearing God loving Etc final thought
I only a couple of seconds please
um this is God okay with a closed border
it's much bigger than that God believes
that in in sovereignty and national
identity and the sanctity of family and
all the things that we've lived with
from the beginning God also has chosen
for it over Chevy he's really weighing
in on every issue we have time and he
knows that the open border is Satan's
way of taking control of the world
through all of these uh people who are
his fujas and his and his servants and
they may think that they're going to
become Gods that's what they tell us you
all know a Harari and and all the rest
of them at the world economic Forum you
know the ones who want us eating insects
cockroaches and that well they dine uh
on the blood of children those are the
people right I love how Eric balling is
like right because you know the ones
that want us eating the insects and the
Cockroaches and dining on the blood of
children right right who's sicker the
person saying this stuff the host taking
it seriously or the audience members who
believe it I don't have the answer but
they're all pretty sick in my book
a Herschel Walker
continues to double triple quadruple
down on this fake police badge the na
the latest example of this is that
Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker brought a bunch of
sheriffs onto his stage at a campaign
event
so that he could again flash his fake
police badge now remember no matter how
many sheriffs and FBI agents and uh you
know Secret Service and U.S Marshals I
don't care who you put on that stage it
doesn't make your stupid badge any more
indicative of you actually being a law
enforcement officer look at this latest
embarrassment I want you guys to know uh
I'm gonna always support them yep
I'm going to always support them that's
the cue guys and what's happening is
Herschel Walker is now turning he took
out his badge and in unison I mean look
at it just instantly all these guys
behind him going to take out their
badges to prove what to prove what I'm
gonna always support them and stuff and
I want to thank them for all what they
do because uh what they're doing is
toughest time
in the United States of America whether
what they're doing is the toughest time
in the United States of America or not
Herschel Walker's badge is an honorary
meaningless badge he's not a police
officer think about how far things have
fallen where there's a guy running
who says I'm a police officer and he's
not
and people go
I'll vote for him
he's just lying he's just it's just made
up he's not a police officer he pulls
out a badge he's not a police officer
but he says he is he says he's trained
with the FBI he hasn't yeah but I don't
know but he's against abortion
but he's not because he paid for a woman
to get an abortion and urged her to have
another one yeah but he'll vote against
abortion
oh okay I understand this is an
embarrassment to the United States let
me know your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
dpacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course a
viewer supported program a listener
supported program the primary means
through which that support takes place
is the membership program you can sign
up at joinpakman.com you can use the
coupon code big voting22 and there is of
course very limited time left until that
big voting Day in the United States
you'll get the daily bonus show the
commercial free audio and video feeds of
the show and invitations to the world
famous truly world famous
members only Town Halls which are a
really big deal joinpakman.com is the
place to sign up let's go to the phones
and by phones we haven't really used
phones in a long time we use Discord uh
at davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to hear from some
of you which I think is a really great
thing to do let's start with Jeff in
Tulsa Oklahoma Jeff welcome to the
program
hi David
um
I really appreciate uh you know your
efforts to uh shoot straight with us and
um you know not mislead us
um regardless of your political position
on an issue
um and I think that you stick to that
almost all the time
um but there's one thing lately that
I've noticed you continue
um to repeat that I think is a little
bit weird so I just wanted to ask you
about that sure
um so you've talked about the
um pandemic stimulus payments and
um you know it's a popular right-wing
talking point you know that Biden has
created all this inflation with the
stimulus and then
um you you like to say well
if you're not happy with Biden's
stimulus payments then you have to be
doubly unhappy with with trumps
and um
my my issue with that is
um I think that there's a massive
difference between
the first round of stimulus payments
that were issued uh when you know we
were still falling off a cliff
economically and
um and then Biden's payments which you
know the I feel like the economy had
um recovered quite a bit at that point
so
um I'm not even making a comment about
whether I think that Biden should or
shouldn't have or whether it's actually
created the inflation that it has but I
do think that there's a difference
between those payments that came first
regardless who did them and those
payments that came last certainly there
is a difference they were also half the
number of dollars that Trump did right
so it was also the totality of what
Biden did is significantly smaller would
you agree with that
absolutely yes and then the other
difference I would argue is it didn't
include the PPP which was so abused
abused and riddled with fraud and
contained so much waste of money going
to organizations that didn't need it and
and abused even by uh many of the very
people on the Republican side who were
opposed to it so Biden didn't include
that in his stimulus which also to me
would would seem to make it more
reasonable in a way so yes I mean it
nothing is exactly the same it was a
different time it was half the amount of
money it didn't include PPP
um but sure yeah I mean we can talk
about the details of the difference but
for people who just blankets say Biden's
one stimulus is the reason for inflation
but trumps too have nothing to do with
inflation I think those people are
either wrong or hypocritical
yes I agree with you on that completely
I just think that
um it's a little more nuanced than
um Biden did one Trump did too so we
should feel doubly about about trump it
is more nuanced than that and at every
opportunity we're adding that Nuance is
feasible I am glad to do it
all right well thank you for everything
David all right thank you very much
appreciate the call let's go next to
Grant from Iowa City Grant welcome to
the show what's going on
hey David so I am about a decade late
and asking this question okay but I
haven't really paid attention to
politics uh up until the last couple
years ago okay anyway
um I was thinking back to Obama's
presidency and how there was such
drama surrounding his birth certificate
and all that of course and I was curious
um how what's your perspective on
requirement for people to be natural
born citizens in order to be eligible
for president yeah
just a little bit before I mean listen
um I I am more in the direction of
uh naturalized citizens should be
eligible primarily for the reason that
without that you really are creating
sort of two tiers of citizens you've got
everybody's a citizen on paper but some
are kind of like more citizens than
others if that makes sense now I do
think that it would be reasonable to say
naturalized citizens can be president
but you you have to have some additional
you know you've lived in the U.S for x
amount of years I'm completely open to
something like that but I mean listen
not that I have any interest in running
for president I was five when I moved to
the United States I've been here more
than 30 years
does it really make sense for me not to
be allowed to be president on that basis
I mean I grew up here uh I've only voted
here I've only worked here I don't know
it just it it doesn't really seem like
that's that that's problematic but I am
fine with there being some requirement
where you know you you if you've only
been here uh if you're only been a
citizen for a year maybe you can't be
president but I'll have to tell you I
also understand the argument of just
letting the people decide if the voters
say hey you know what even though this
person's a citizen they've only been a
citizen a year I don't think that that's
who we need as president you could also
make the case that you don't even really
need a rule it should just be up to the
voters to decide so yeah for me I am
significantly in the direction of
allowing naturalized citizens to run for
president
right that makes sense to me too because
I can completely understand I think the
current requirement is you have to live
in the U.S for 14 years or be a citizen
for 14 years and you have to be 35 and
like that makes sense to me uh the 35
years years old is of an arbitrary
number but yeah I guess it's
understandable you want people to have
life experience that makes sense to me
but
yeah the idea that you have to be a
natural born citizen is some people you
literally can't uh
it's not an option for people to have
like like for yourself and I know you do
not plan to run but um like everyone has
the uh at least possibility of living in
the U.S for 18 years if you have the
funds to make it here and and you know
make the move yeah but you can't go back
in history and be born somewhere else
that's for sure right exactly yeah so
all right grant well thank you I
appreciate the question
can I asked one um extra little thing
here oh sure
sure
um do you see there being a possibility
of that requirement being changed in the
future would is that that could be
twister is it too uh sure yeah I mean I
I see a possibility of it although it
doesn't seem like there's really any big
movement that's getting attention
pushing for it right now so I wouldn't
expect it to happen anytime soon
okay
very good all right well thanks for
taking my call all right thanks Grant
there's Grant from Iowa City with a very
important question which everyone will
say my opinion doesn't matter because
I'm biased or something like that well
then listen to someone else's opinion
let's go to Smitty from Los Angeles
Smitty what's going on
good morning David how are you I'm doing
well sorry
don't cut me off
[Music]
um
sorry I didn't mean this habit
um well I just want to say after as I've
continued to listen to you I have
discovered that pretty much my politics
are exactly where yours is at wow I mean
I I definitely feel like you know
there's just certain things that
you know that we need to take a hold of
from a public perspective with
um education with environment with you
know just certain industries that we
should really have more
you know control over from the
government perspective with a lot of
accountability I think one of the issues
is also accountability
um
and this is my question do you think it
really is so much about left and right
or do you think it really is more about
accountability and do you think that it
really is a matter of how you structure
your society that really having that
accountability behind it so
could you be a capitalist society as
long as there's like a lot of
accountability
or could you have a more socialist
society with a lot of accountability I
feel like we do our stuff at Injustice
playing this Left Right game I think
it's more about that than it is about
you know other stuff that isn't I I
don't know that I would say it's really
about accountability I mean on many
issues it is about where you are on the
political Spectrum
um you know a woman's right to choose I
don't think it's about accountability
now what I will say is like for example
for many right Wingers who oppose
abortion being legal
they like to take this approach of well
it's about accountability in that if you
engage in the type of sexual activity
that leads to a pregnancy you have to be
accountable by then carrying the
pregnancy to term but I don't think
that's the type of accountability you're
talking about
um
I'm sorry it's more on the um you know
the economical side I've definitely like
far you know far left on people should
be allowed to do what they do and yeah
no I wasn't suggesting they were taking
any particular position on abortion no I
don't I don't think I'm there I don't
think I'm there on accountability you
know a lot of times there's this
Instinct sometimes and I'd say this not
to criticize you but because a lot of
people do this there's this instinct to
find sort of like the grand thing that
explains everything so often in society
where people will come and they'll say
you know
fundamentally all politics is about
campaign finance and it's like well a
lot of it is but there's also a lot of
other stuff that's not about that and
sometimes people will call in and
they'll say something like what you're
saying you know fundamentally it's not
really about left right it's about
accountability I think the the world is
so complicated that I wouldn't even
waste time looking for the one thing
that it's really about everything is
about a lot of different things and I
think that's the approach we should have
okay well that's good enough I do think
the accountability is definitely a big
part of it but all right but yes I take
all your weeks so thank you for your
feedback all right Smitty from La great
to hear from you always appreciate it
let's go to I hope I pronounced this
correctly is this is it fit Phineas or
pineus from Kansas how do you pronounce
that
hi David uh it's Phineas Phineas it's
actually based on Phineas Gage well
welcome to the program see you today sir
uh I wanted to say first and foremost
love the program huge fan uh I wanted to
ask why certain Democratic entities
would spend money specifically I'm in
Kansas why they would spend money to get
people to turn out for uh an abortion
vote but then turn around and not invest
any money in like a governor race or our
Senate race
oh uh well because they see so so you're
saying why would they spend money
advertising that there is like a ballot
initiative on abortion or a referendum
and then right the very same people
don't invest in like saying go vote for
this gubernatorial candidate who might
have a similar view on abortion for
example
the results of the recent Kansas
election and say Hey you know we got
favorable results and then turn around
abandon has come midterms I have no idea
you'd have to ask you'd have to ask them
I think I'm just not really I'm not
really sure why you know why other
people would or would not spend money in
a certain way I'm not really sure I mean
there are some groups that only work on
ballot initiatives in referenda and then
don't work on candidate races but I I
don't I think I I just don't have all
the information to be able to give you
an explanation
I do appreciate your time on the ballot
initiative
thank you very much Dave all right
Phineas sounds like you've got a lot
going on there in Kansas so I will let
you go let's go next to LJ from Las
Vegas LJ what's going on in Vegas these
days
um uh very close uh race with uh Adam
laxalt and uh basically the worst
Democratic uh you know candidate that
could ever exist but yes you know
we will be watching that one very
closely on Election night
yeah it's it's the sad fact that people
always like to complain about like you
know the pro the uh the candidates that
are available during the picture in the
general election while I'm screaming
here it's like that's why we have
primaries and why we should go vote
during primaries which is a more
important time indeed other than the
actual General but that's neither here
nor there what's on your mind today
I was actually wondering uh regarding
the the messaging that we have regarding
taxing and just like this you know uh
taxation is best so you know I used to
be a person of the Horizon uh I grew up
my entire life a person on the right and
as I've gotten older and I've got access
to more information and more points of
views yes I've learned you know that
there are some things that I do uh
believe I should stay conservative on
but when it comes to taxation I feel
like the the messaging that we have here
in the United States is all wrong right
and I've been watching Jon Stewart's uh
videos on it so if you have a chance or
really good
yes and so I think the messaging that we
have in the here the US is that you know
like when we're being taxed it's money
that's being taken away from us rather
than money that's being invested towards
us yeah right no that's for sure
and I I really do think that when you
have those conversations where I was
watching your debate coverage the other
day whereas uh I forgot I think it was
in Georgia with uh
God I can't remember the candidate that
was the well Georgia was Herschel Walker
and Rafael Warnock oh no
Abrams
yes yes yes yes and I had the
libertarian candidate on there yeah
and he kept screaming over and over
again it's like why don't you let the
American people decide why don't you let
the American people decide and I think
that messaging works because it's it's
saying a lie of course right but the
truth of the matter is is when they say
let the American people decide they say
well we want one person from one
Corporation to decide everything because
that's what benefits us most financially
right so when they say let the American
people decide and they say you know
what's it called Private Industry should
decide this because they're the ones who
can make the best decision yeah I feel
like they're saying no or removing the
option from the government who is voted
on by the American people it's like you
can't go up to your boss and tell them
it's like I want a thousand percent
raise
versus you know
um
being able to vote in primaries and
elections for someone who might give you
benefits for your
so LJ did you have a question today
I'm sorry my question is do you think
that is that the correct messaging so
like that was kind of like where I was
going for here is the messaging that
makes the most sense to me and I'm not a
focus group guy so this may not be
messaging that works but it's messaging
that makes sense to me and we go listen
all this talk about uh taxes or slavery
and all this different stuff you you
guys got to grow up okay if humans are
going to live in groups that need to
organize anything with more than 150
people sociology and anthropology and
group psychology tell us you need to
delegate certain decision making you
need to delegate certain powers you need
to centralize decision making and Powers
because otherwise you're basically
limited to groups of 150 people these
ideas that a million people in a city
are going to just kind of like naturally
organize in the way that these
Libertarians talk about it just does not
work there's no science that tells us
that that works in any discipline so
once you understand and concede that
what we need to do is to have a system
of voting that will make the elected
officials to whom we delegate power most
accurately representative of what the
voters want and part of this includes
that yes
we need to in a society
centralize the collection of taxes in
order to do big projects that just can't
be done by an individual or unilaterally
done by a couple of competing companies
who just sort of fight it out okay and
it's like we just got to be adults I I
can't think of any other way to explain
it
right
no I completely agree because uh with my
libertarian couple libertarian friends
who are who still lean left they're not
like complete like idiots when it comes
to taxation yeah that we all have the
same conversation point that we come
back to is like taxes are you know
incorrectly used like the war in Iraq
sure
um trust that are given to billionaires
who don't need it or to companies who
are doing extremely well still receive
tax cuts right
so or how the oil companies are you know
um in the corn and provided there's a
ton of examples of it but that's
generally my take on how I would talk
about uh taxes all right my friend I
gotta let you go okay
there's LJ from Vegas let's take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we're going right back and we'll
hear from more people in just a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
back to the Discord lines and hear from
a few more people you can join at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go first to uh oh I don't
know how about uh Sean from Miami Sean
what's going on
hello David
[Music]
um
I just want to ask about your thoughts
on the protests going on in Iran that
have lasted over a month at this point
and what you think their effects will be
as in do you expect any kind of liberal
reform or even regime change I feel like
I should not comment about my
expectations because I would just be
spitballing and one of the things I try
to do on the show is if I don't really
have facts on which to base an opinion
why am I just going to interject my
voice I don't need to have an opinion on
everything and so I'm aware of the
protests I know that the goal is liberal
reforms I I simply cannot add anything
productive to the conversation so I'm
going to let the experts continue to
weigh in on that
I totally understand we're generally not
that good at predicting so we're
generally even let's that's another good
point even if I did know more about it
we're terrible at making predictions but
I'm glad to make predictions about
things I know a little bit more about
like for example I've been following the
polling for the midterms very closely
for a year and a half so I'm I'm glad to
make predictions there but uh anyway you
get the point
yeah yeah well thanks for your time
David my pleasure uh great to hear from
our friends in Miami as always reminder
to everybody on the Discord waiting to
get on uh you need to have if you want
the opportunity to get on your name and
where you're calling from it doesn't
have to be real I don't know where
you're really calling from or what your
name is but it can't be nicknames it
can't be usernames it can't be obvious
like name parodies and things like that
okay just a reminder for people who may
be wondering why they're not getting
called on let's go to David from Oakland
David welcome to the program what's on
your mind
thanks for taking my call
um so I just kind of want to get your
opinion on uh the FED policy going
forward and trying to Tamp down
inflation
and I I think what is it that the FED
wants to inflict pain and that how
unemployment they want to put some
people out of work to cool down uh
inflation yeah
um we've seen what uh Jerome Powell has
said and what Senators like Elizabeth
Warren feel about it so I want to get
your opinion on that I am concerned that
inflation is going to come down but it's
going to come down in due time and
slightly more slowly than the FED would
like to see it come down and that as a
result the FED is going to overplay its
hand with the raising of rates and is
going to create too much of an economic
slowdown when partially what we need to
do is just wait because some of this in
inflation is the result of supply chain
issues some of the inflation is a result
of energy prices which have started to
come down and so my concern you know of
course I don't pretend to have all of
the information or to study this as
closely as the people at the FED do but
big picture a general concern with a
with a Fed that becomes committed to
raising rates and raising them for a
significant period of time
is there is more of a delay before the
effect is felt on prices because the
inflation has to do with some seasonal
not seasonal temporary and transient
things that are starting to resolve and
that before you know it the FED will
have gone too far and will damage the
economy that's my concern
that's kind of my concern too and it's
also just such a backwards concept it
seems that they want people out of work
to cool things down and you get the
economics of it right it sounds like you
do right yeah the idea being fewer
people employed fewer people who can
afford stuff reducing demand and then
prices come down yeah exactly
it it it's a weird concept and you know
the market outlook for 2023 I know
markets are forward leaning uh but it
just you know net negative hiring
layoffs it just it's like everybody's
predicting catastrophe and
you know is it gonna be like great my
savings account yields four percent but
I can't find a job or something no I
know I mean listen obviously employment
and being able to meet your monthly
expenses is the top priority for
everyone and absent that people are in
real trouble
for those who will remain employed and
able to afford their day-to-day expenses
my advice is advice that I would give no
matter what's going on figure out your
asset allocation how much you're saving
in cash how much you're putting into
stocks and bonds ideally through super
low cost index funds and if things
continue declining over the next year
you will have picked up more and more
shares at lower and lower prices which
will have eventually yield more return
When Things recover and if things do
well in the next year then the shares
that you already own will be worth more
at the end of that year either way as
long as your outlook is more than a few
years out you're going to better
position yourself for five to seven
years from now and that's the funny
thing is that's always my advice no
matter what's going on
well that's why we watched the Pac-Man
Finance Channel exactly right so thanks
for taking my call my pleasure my
pleasure and a pre you you uh you super
chat often during the live streams right
yeah it's Bay photo I very much
appreciate that thanks for the support
of course all right there we go David
from Oakland with a very important
economic question super powerful
declaration and I really appreciate that
let's go next to Ben from San Angelo Ben
welcome to the program
hello David can you hear me I can
all right so my question today was
actually about polls
um New York Times and Siena College poll
recently found that there was a 32 point
shift in Independent Women
um based on whether they wanted to have
Republicans in office Or democrats in
office my question was what do you think
is the biggest reason why there was that
shift now you didn't say what the shift
was was the assuming this is the same
poll I saw this is a shift where young
women have moved more in the direction
of the democratic party is that right
oh
um well actually
um the poll shows that
um there was a 32-point swing among
Independent Women for to vote for the
GOP oh okay let me pull that up then uh
Independents especially women are
swinging oh to the GOP oh interesting
yeah it's bad I have not seen that poll
and so it would be mere speculation I
have no idea why that's going on it
could have something to do with the
specific can't I'm just not sure I
haven't seen that I've just found it now
that you mentioned it I had not seen
that poll does the does the do any of
the Articles speculate about why that
shift has taken place yes
um what I think the biggest thought is
is that it has the economy
um abortion abortion rights have kind of
taken a back seat and independent women
who were once uh Furious or upset about
the Dobbs decision are now falling back
on the economy and
um I guess they're a acclimating to the
new world I guess that's a plausible
explanation and in fact in a recent
segment earlier this week I talked about
that have we just was the timing of the
Roe v Wade decision early enough that it
had an impact and that impact is now
diminishing I just don't think that
explains a 32-point swing that is
massive
um I guess I wanted the second question
then I'll go
um that I had
um was do you think that
um the Republican tactics of flipping uh
the debate on abortion saying that it's
the Democrats who are radical for
wanting to keep Roe versus Wade do you
think that that has been very effective
in saying that no not at all because
support for Roe v Wade has only
increased since the 1973 decision so I
ca I can't imagine that that has that no
no I don't think so
okay well thank you so much for taking
my call David my pleasure great to hear
from you always great to hear from our
friends in San Angelo as is always the
case let's go next to Matt from Arizona
things are pretty hectic in Arizona I
must say Matt between the Kerry Lake
situation Blake Masters it's wacky down
there
Matt from Arizona you're welcome
that's exactly what I was going to talk
about me and my wife talking about that
yesterday yeah
well go ahead what's going on
and my daughter is screaming in my ears
something cool
you are on the air Matt I don't know if
you had anything you wanted to say or
ask
oh okay
um well just just the same thing you
know Cary Lake I can't even understand
how people are even wanting to vote for
her like based upon abortion rights
that's me and my wife's probably biggest
thing just because that's kind of the
biggest thing in Arizona right now and
uh do you ever have you met people in
person where
they say I like Carrie Lake I'm
supporting her
no you have not I don't even know
I don't I don't hang out with those type
of people oh okay all right well but how
do you know not to hang out with them
unless they mention it
say it again I'm so sorry listen it
sounds like you got a lot going on there
man yeah you understand that all right
I'll let you go yeah it sounds crazy it
sounds like uh careful with those diaper
blowouts okay very very careful they
could be lethal all right let's continue
here um yeah he just had too much going
on let's go to John from Jersey John
what's going on today
hey David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
uh so you've been talking a lot lately
about anti-Semitism which is a subject I
think about a lot
um so I I'm a copt uh which is a
Christian ethno religious group mostly
from Egypt yes uh so growing up around
other cops uh I always heard some dark
anti-semitic comments like you know a
lot of it with the whole you know Christ
killer or sometimes you know they have
the evil eye they're pale with no soul
yeah and as vile and as vile as these
comments are what really puzzles me is
the phenomenon of the typical tropes
like uh you know they stick together and
help each other you know they're they're
cheap
um you know and and
um what's hypocritical about this is a
lot of these like common tropes are
actually traits that are in the Coptic
community and they're almost like
revered except you know you're not
called cheap you're called like Frugal
and like uh you know uh crafty and and
things like that uh you're not called uh
uh you know that something bad about
sticking together no you you know you're
part of a community uh right so I just
wanted to thank you for one of the funny
ones sorry sorry to inter but one of the
funny ones is you know when people go oh
Jews they just love money it's like
right black people hate money white
people hate money Italian people hate
money Jews are the ones that love money
it's just it's all so stupid
yeah so I mean I mean it's it's uh it's
very transparent and hypocritical I I
why why is it that it's something that's
that's still a trade among you know
really most most people
which part is a trait the the having the
anti-semitic beliefs or what well I
guess I guess the the
um like hate for Jews like what what is
it what is it that makes Jews uh so
unique or or the focal point of uh of
you know the whole world really there's
a bunch of factors here so let I'll list
some of them okay
there are historical factors which
blaming Jews for thousands of years has
been a shorthand that can be used
whenever there's a problem is it they're
responsible for the plague or they're
responsible for Killing Jesus or they're
responsible for
um uh the American college and
universities becoming left-wing whatever
so first of all it's it's just it's been
a shorthand for a long time too as you
mentioned many of the tropes actually
sort of apply to everyone but and so
when so it's very easy to say oh well
you know Jews love money and are cheap
it's like most people like money and try
to avoid spending more money than they
need to but when it's only applied to
one group you can very easily find what
you're looking for that's a second thing
third thing there is a difference with
some Jews remember there's some Jews are
darker skinned lighter skin whatever in
Western societies it's true that in many
cases you can't tell by looking at
someone whether they're Jewish obviously
most Jews aren't wearing a yamaka or
peace or you know all these different
things so you can't tell when you look
at someone and to some of these
anti-semites that becomes part of why
they are targeted because it's seen
almost as part of the deception you know
they walk around Among Us and you can't
even tell who's who someone's a woman
you can tell by looking at them if
someone's black you can tell by looking
at them Etc so it almost feeds upon its
own Trope about the idea of deception
and hiding out in plain sight and so all
these different little historical and
modern realities and then there's
another thing which people love to talk
about this oh why are Jewish folks over
represented in some Industries and they
love to talk about law or entertainment
or whatever right there's a historical
discrimination reason why that's the
case case Jews were banned for so long
and in so many places from participating
in so many industries that there was
this de facto push
to concentrate in Industries where you
can not necessarily have to physically
engage with certain industries in
particular ways and it's because of
discrimination that you now see some of
that phenomena today not because of Any
Grand conspiracy to control Industries
as anti-semites often say it's because
of discrimination where Jews were
crossed off from a whole bunch of
Industries you can't be here you can't
be here you can't be here okay well
what's left
right right uh that that's something
similar to a lot of other uh uh trades
or uh professions like you know uh Irish
Americans uh in the law enforcement
Community sure things like that yep
um thanks David thanks for giving me
your take on this uh I appreciate you
have time for another question you know
we are out of time okay thanks for
taking my call all right your first one
was good though so I really appreciate
it all right everybody we're gonna go to
a break sorry I wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take calls again
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get right into our
Friday mailbag the Friday mailbag I have
to say on average has been improving in
quality with occasional really horrible
emails but you can email info
davidpackman.com if you have something
to say uh sometimes people will ask for
Corrections in the Friday mailbag if
they are appropriate I'm glad to give
them we don't hide the corrections you
know on the last page of the paper or
anything like that we put them at the
top of the mailbag when appropriate okay
let's start first email is from Bob this
is kind of interesting Bob sends some
questions for the future
and says hey David I'm from the year
3328 I was watching your show in the
historical archives and found it
insightful I was hoping you could give
me perspective on issues people are
dealing with today one do you think
clone marriage should be legal now see I
don't even understand that do you mean
clones of the same person marrying each
other or just clones in general getting
married
but probably yeah I mean I don't know
they're different people sure number two
should genetic engineering be guaranteed
coverage by health insurance probably I
Believe by 3328 there at least will be
insurance for that three are alien
species fit to serve in Earth politics
if they are legal citizens 100 I believe
if you are a naturalized Earthling uh
even if you come from a different planet
and listen if you speak the language if
you understand our system if you share
our values who do I sound like uh now I
I don't know on Aliens
um from other planets being being
politicians should AI be able to vote I
think no on that
and number five is debris pollution from
asteroid gov mining something the
government should try to regulate in the
wake of the recent Mars freighter
disaster I would say yes sir I think I
would be very much able to make
decisions about
30 year 3328 uh World governance I like
that Bob really giving giving us
something to think about there
let's go next to Michael writing in
about Alex Jones
Michael says David do you think Alex
Jones is now a suicide risk if so is he
likely to take others with him I think
he should be carefully watched when you
consider his obsession with Firearms his
pathological anger and the impossibility
of ever recovering from the verdict
against him I believe he has been backed
into a corner his agenda has been chaos
and destruction from the beginning and
now he will take it to the Limit I fear
I would not be surprised to hear of his
committing a mass murder suicide I hope
there are people around him who can
prevent this
um I wonder the same of trump if
DeSantis wins the primary no so so the
there there are good questions here
I don't think Trump is liable to do
self-harm if DeSantis defeats him in the
primary I don't
I do see Alex Jones as a possible
self-harm risk I don't get the sense of
Alex Jones necessarily taking others
down with him
I know that many of you might be
surprised and say his rhetoric about
others is really wacky
Maybe I'm Wrong I see Alex Jones
primarily physically speaking as a risk
to himself
next to email is from Alan Allen argues
in response to what I asked last week
are trumpists too far gone
Allen says Trump supporters are not too
far gone and writes David sir you
recently asked on your show if Trump
supporters are too far gone if they
could be put in the right environment I
say no however many Trump supporters
only consume TV programs that reinforce
their positions or are being funneled
into extremist media in their social
media by AI TV hosts and social media
companies are making tons of money off
of all this and it will not stop without
some kind of legislation
the legislation is not coming because
these people are voting in more extreme
politicians who either have the same
goals or also profit I have lost a
friend but she was not lost to Trump At
first she was funneled into Q Anon by
Twitter if I ever get the motivation
I'll send some old chat threads they are
insane I do agree with one aspect of
this which is I do think a complete
environmental shift for these trumpists
would have an impact because we have a
study that says that I don't know if it
was like nine months or maybe a year or
18 months ago we had a study that
measured the effect what happens if you
take trumpists or I think it was like
Fox News viewers people who primarily or
exclusively get their news from Fox
you take them out of that and you give
them a month of something different and
they tested a few different something
different and their views did begin to
change but it required getting off of
the Fox News so
I I agree with Alan very difficult to
make that happen Carl wrote in with one
of the many Corrections about my
interview with my pillow CEO Mike
Lindell as I told you all it's really
hard to correct everything when someone
tells hundreds of Lies during an
interview one of the things pillow
claimed was that all the 2020 election
lawsuits that were thrown out were
thrown out for standing and not on the
merits it turns out that's not true Carl
wrote to me about it and said please pin
Mike Lindell down next time on the 60
election suits issue most were dismissed
for lack of evidence not the right-wing
claim repeated a trillion times that
they were all dismissed for lack of
standing
this is an easy one with court document
proof yes great information if he's back
on or if someone else tries that talking
point on me I will be prepared it can be
really difficult to prepare for every
talking point and I didn't have examples
specific examples in front of me
Brewster also wrote in about the
interview with Mike pillow says David
I'm a big fan and I count on you to
provide me the latest and most accurate
news however I do have some criticism
about your interview with Mike it was
unnecessary for you to correct Mike's
mispronunciations it made you look like
you were trying to demonstrate how much
more educated you are than him there
were far more important topics to cover
so the only correction I made was that
he pronounced Kamala Harris's name
incorrectly
and for me that's not about education
right Wingers
don't even respect her enough
to learn how her name is said I believe
there is much more to the constant
mispronunciation of Kamala Harris's name
for these right Wingers why do the left
Wingers it's not education why do the
left-waners know how to pronounce it and
the right Wingers don't I believe there
is a xenophobic racist component to it
and it's a an Indra I mean listen guys
it's when I jokingly say tool C gabbard
right
what am I doing when I do that we all
know what I'm doing okay I'm doing it on
purpose with them I don't know if they
just don't actually respect the person
enough to know what they're naming I
know it's not Dan bongino it's Dan
bongino
all right
uh next email is from James would the
Army using electric vehicles convince
right-wingers to go electric another
left Progressive YouTuber brought up
that the Department of Defense is
looking for a new light Recon vehicle
and intended intend on that being an
electric vehicle the current proposal is
a militarized version of General Motors
Hummer electric vehicle he thinks this
will be what pushes the anti-electric
vehicle right into embracing AVS because
that crowd has a strong pull towards
trying to imitate the military I'm not
so sure that the rights desire for
tactical is strong enough to wipe out
wipe out the stupid impression that EVS
will somehow emasculate them yeah I
agree if the military became known for
really rugged electric vehicles
I do believe that that would push a
bunch of right-wingers to at least be
open to electric vehicles the electric
F-150 has made significant inroads I
don't know the status of the electric
Hummer but sounds like that maybe that
would as well
but there is going to be it it's going
to be sort of a stubborn belief that
electric vehicles are terrible and bad
and feminine and all this stuff for a
while but I think if the Army started
using EVS it would make a difference
Chris asks a good question who is they
asks Chris uh David love your show have
a question who is they why is it that
the right always says they are taking
your rights they don't want you to know
they hate America for a group that hates
pronouns it is odd how they lean on the
mysterious they so much in responding to
legitimate questions don't you think
keep up the good work yeah I mean listen
they is a catch-all for some combination
of Democrats marxists socialists
Communists wokists antifa BLM sometimes
Jews if it's inconvenient sometimes
minorities sometimes they can be
anything they can be whatever best fits
the story so if they go
they're holding you down they're not
letting you live the life you want to
live could be anybody and depending on
whether the story is about the US
government or some shadowy Elite cabal
or who knows it's just a fill in the
blank and they'll just go through it and
try try again until they get something
that fits I now I have to say
sometimes the word they does come
naturally once you've already made clear
who you're talking about so sometimes
I'll say
in a story I'll open it by saying the uh
most religious element of the American
right wing has decided that they are
going to vote on an election and
election only and then I'll say more
stuff and then later I'll say they
I'm referring back to that same very
most religious element of the American
right wing I try to remind myself I
should try to restate who it is I'm
talking about
to avoid falling into this they thing so
Chris's email is a good reminder
Busta wrote in about voter fraud I
actually can't tell if this is for Real
Busta says how could you possibly do
that long of a response video about what
would convince you that there was voter
fraud and not talk about 2 000 mules the
movie was cheesy with its use of dark
rooms and drama but the evidence was
extremely compelling two thousand mules
is exactly the voter fraud evidence you
said you would accept I don't know if
this person is for real or not two
thousand meals was a joke we've already
gone through this multiple times two
thousand mules is based on very specious
geolocation data of mobile phones that
they have not even actually connected to
voting related activities it is
completely speculative it doesn't
actually show anything other than
supposedly certain people with mobile
phones were grouped in different areas
that they claim are suspicious close to
ballot drop boxes
that's all they have
I'm simplifying a little bit it was not
compelling
it was not compelling and if someone
thinks that 2 000 meals is proof of
anything other than Dinesh d'souza's
delusion and narcissism
then I don't know that we have much to
talk about
we have a great bonus show for you today
don't miss the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah especially in
this era of Alex Jones hating the bonus
show thank your lucky stars every day
you're not Dave Pacman well all right
Alex thank you very much uh it is a
great time to sign up at joinpakman.com
joinpakman.com coupon code big voting 22
just a couple weeks left before the big
voting day hope you'll sign up and I'll
see you on the boat show